in his latest orange rant the failed
former and wannabe future president
Donald Trump is promising mandatory
homeless camps he looks completely
disoriented he looks swollen as usual
his right eye almost completely shut but
he says that he will ban homelessness
hey who knew homelessness had such a
simple solution just ban it by the way
ban the virus while you're at it let's
get rid of everything and he says that
there will be tent camps for the
homeless outside of cities this is so
deranged we heard him talk about it at
rallies but it is now being put out as
an actual idea of of policy if you can
call it policy for Trump's 2024 run
let's take a look at this then I'm going
to talk to you about the ugly dystopian
history of camps for people ban Urban
camp
treatment
and services if they're willing to be
rehabilitated many of them don't want
that
we'll give them the option we will then
open up large Parcels of inexpensive
land bring in doctors psychiatrists
social workers and drug rehab
Specialists and create 10 cities where
the homeless can be relocated and their
problems identified
but we'll open up our cities again make
them livable and make them beautiful to
ban Urban care so listen pretending to
take this seriously for a second
I'm not big on tent cities and there's a
lot of historical precedent for these
sorts of camps being some of the ugliest
things that societies do I mean not only
is it inhumane and violates basic human
rights it also doesn't work and I always
think it's important when we talk about
these things to talk to those who might
support such a policy not only
ideologically but also pragmatically so
the first problem is that banning
homelessness in this way it assumes that
homelessness is a choice or a behavior
that you can eliminate with the right
punishment and that's a flawed
assumption at its core it ignores that
homelessness has so many complex factors
that causes it poverty is of course part
of it it's simple to say well poor
homeless people are poor poor people are
more likely to become homeless yes
that's absolutely true mental illness is
a component addiction is a component
lack of affordable housing in cities is
a component lack of effective public
transportation that can link lower
income residential areas with areas
where the jobs are is a factor I could
go on there's so many different factors
but what it should the takeaway should
be is
if you just criminalize homelessness it
doesn't really solve anything so when
you try to ban homelessness and you try
to force homeless people to live in a
tent camp outside of a city where I
guess they would be bussed to it once
you're there there's no jobs you're in
the middle of nowhere and and there's a
tent camp and that's it you're doing
nothing to address the underlying
conditions that got people to be
homeless in the first place but what you
do is you further marginalize them you
stigmatize the homeless population
because you're actually separating them
and saying oh if you're homeless you're
being brought out there
to the camp where you have no shot at
getting a job I mean forget about it
um and you actually perpetuate the
problem and make it even worse now if
you want to look at some historical
examples of this type of approach to
homelessness there are many historical
failures in the 20th century many
countries implemented mandatory
institutionalization programs for
homeless people and the idea is we're
going to provide shelter and treatment
which is arguably a good a nice thing
right I mean when Trump says we're going
to get people things that they need
we'll get them sheltered we'll get them
food we'll get them treatment at least
on an interim basis once we've
completely separated them from society
we know from the 20th century examples
that they end up being overcrowded
unsanitary
abusive very little effective treatment
provided
stigmatizing and alienating and
segregating so it doesn't actually
accomplish anything and what you end up
with is with many of these homeless
folks essentially trapped in these
places for years with conditions they
may have worsening
chances of reintegrating into society
dramatically decreasing and meanwhile
the homeless population continues to
swell another example of this
is looking specifically at tent cities
to house homeless populations in the
early 2000s there were cities in the
Pacific Northwest that established some
tent cities for homeless people and the
idea is temporary shelter temporary
shelter and exactly what I just
described to you is is what took place
they became overcrowded they became
unsanitary they weren't even properly
funded there was limited access to basic
amenities running water was scarce
sanitation facilities were leaving much
to be desired and they actually became
hot spots for crime and drug abuse which
only made the problem worse marginalized
people stigmatize them and you're not
making it more likely that they will be
what Republicans like to describe as
productive members of society so instead
of punishing with further marginalizing
programs for a population that's already
vulnerable we should instead be working
towards what causes the homelessness
imagine you say hey look all these
homeless people
let's not even think about what made
them homeless let's just ship them off
in bus buses to the desert and have them
live in tents indefinitely until what
until what happens so poverty lack of
affordable housing lack of support for
people
in their communities rather than by
separating them these are the types of
things that will help people reintegrate
into society and many of these programs
that are proposed and often underfunded
they're actually quite Revenue neutral
because yes they cost money but if you
care mostly about the finances they
eventually generate government revenue
by getting some fraction of those people
back to work paying taxes spending money
in the community so there's even a
fiscal conservatism argument to be made
swollen Trump though
I don't think he's ready to have this
conversation I love my car which is
electric I love my bicycle and I have to
say that the perfect medium in between
is my electric bike by Electric if
you're looking to spend about 800 or so
on an e-bike electric is where you want
to go I've tried e-bikes that cost seven
thousand dollars and electric delivers
the same performance and specs but at a
much more reasonable price point I take
my electric e-bike everywhere these days
I've almost completely ditched my
regular bike for now e-bikes are of
course better for the environment than
taking a car the e-bike gives you more
flexibility and range than a regular
bicycle you can go further you can see
more my e-bike is just my favorite form
of cardio at this point it comes fully
assembled to your door it includes a
bright LCD display seven speed gearing
five levels of pedal assist and a
powerful battery that's removable so you
can bring it indoors for charging it's
also fully foldable so I can put it in
the back of my car and they have
financing for as little as 73 bucks a
month go to electricebikes.com to learn
more explore all of the incredible
e-bike models they offer the link is
down below